my best friend  indulge me when I show my gratitude  representatives yeah then they're no  friends of mine you see my trainer  forever thank you  would you guys like cream and sugar yeah  like I would like real trick we're fine  you hear that that's that that man to  Central America experienced by hand  Washington pulps them rose to them and  you're like oh no buddy I'm good  I'm just gonna put run it do you guys  see in a minute no no no we I just I  would like me to this thank you as your  friend trying to show you the way  okay you don't want to see it that's  fine  215 degrees really four degrees under  boil point max  really well the big bubbles in the pot  when you're making the water  I'm gonna do you a favor okay okay check  my kids I'm not meeting my best friend  indulge me when I say my god